>> Hey, there and welcome to the course.
I'm Jessica Olman.
>> And I'm Cameron Pittman.
We're going to be your instructors for this course.
>> Now, you're probably wondering why this course is
called Not Your Typical Intro to HTML and CSS.
That's because we're not going to show you how to
make a web page with a title and some body to start.
Instead, we're going to show you a methodical way of
breaking down a current web page and recreating it for your own purposes.
>> Hm, you know, HTML and CSS develop and change over time.
But the underlying principles will always remain the same.
Once you get a hang of those,
learning the specific techniques is going to become a lot easier.
In the first lesson, you'll learn how to look at a basic design mockup and
translate it to HTML and CSS to create a basic web page.
>> And in the second lesson, you'll develop a CSS framework,
which will help you make websites much faster and easier.
Along the way, you'll learn about responsive design, which is a principle that
will help you reach people on any device that they're using to see your website.
In the last lesson, you'll be taking on a professional framework.
You'll be building a static website using Twitter's Bootstrap framework,
which is what professionals use in the field every day.
>> Now, this course is just the beginning of your journey to
become a front-end web developer.
Here you'll build the foundations of your own online portfolio.
>> We are really excited to have you.
So, welcome to class and let's get started